This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
for our psychology. Before we begin the episode, I just want to let you all know that this episode will include discussions of sex, including sexual assault and sexual trauma. So if this topic is one that is particularly upsetting for you, please feel free to stop listening now. This episode will still be here in a week, a month, a year. So just consider your current mental headspace and your ability to listen to stories and advice about these themes. There will be resources in the episode description if needed. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode, back for another
December guest episode. And we break down the psychology of our 20s. When I was thinking about who I wanted to invite on this December and what I wanted to discuss, I thought a lot about a DM that I received from a listener asking me to talk about sexual confidence, specifically, how to move past sexual shame from your past and feel like your pleasure is something that is important and that you can advocate for. And it was a really amazing question, one that we've really never answered before on the podcast, despite definitely being an important theme in our 20s. So I wanted to talk about it today. How can we enjoy the sex we're having despite shame from the past? How can we be more confident? How can we really know what we are after? So much,
about sex comes down to psychology and our mental state and how we're influenced by emotional wounds, attachment, past memories, attitudes, not just towards sex, but towards ourselves. And today we have one of an amazing guest who has a deep expertise in all of these topics. Dr. Emily Jamir, welcome to the psychology of your 20s. Thank you for having me, Gemma. I am so thrilled to be here. And can I just say I wish that this podcast had existed when I was in my 20s. because you have so many great episodes with so much information. So I am so thrilled to be a part of it.
Thank you so much. That's a nice little compliment to start out the episode. I really appreciate that. Can you briefly introduce your work and yourself and what you do? Sure. So I am a sex and relationship therapist. I am based in Houston, Texas. In addition to my clinical practice, I do a lot of public speaking. I just released a book. in November called Anatomy of Desire, Five Secrets to Create Connection and Cultivate Passion, so be sure to check that out. And, you know, as much as possible, I just try to get the word out wherever I can to whomever I can. So there's so much to say about what makes sex great and what we can do to experience that. And so I just love, you know, taking as many opportunities that I can like this. Yeah. Well, we're really, we're really.
really, really excited to have you on. And it's a bit of a, it's a bit of a deep vulnerable topic. So I was like, we need an expert to discuss this, because sexual shame is something that I think a lot of us actually have, but not many of us have the proper words to talk about. And I really want to talk about, I really want to discuss the various ways that shame actually shows up, right, because it's not just one type of experience. What have you tended to find in your practice and your work are the biggest sources of of sexual shame for people, not just in their 20s, but throughout their lives? I think we have to start by defining sexual shame because it is such a big term that, to your
point, can show up and manifest itself in so many different ways. I really love Noelle Clark's definition of sexual shame. She is, she did pioneering research on the topic and actually won a presidential award. So I'd like to share her definition because it is the best. So sexual shame is a visceral feeling of humiliation and disgust for one's own body and identity as a sexual being. It is a belief of being abnormal, inferior and unworthy. This feeling can, be internalized but also manifests in our interpersonal relationships having a negative impact on trust, communication, and physical and emotional intimacy. Sexual shame develops across the lifespan in interactions and interpersonal relationships, one's culture and society, and subsequent critical self-appraisal. There is also a fear of uncertainty with one's power or right to make decisions, including safety decisions related to sexual encounters along with an internalized judgment about
one's own sexual desire. Oh my goodness. A big definition. There's a lot packed into that definition. And that is because sexual shame is slimy. It is sticky. It comes from all different places and can kind of work its way into different nooks and crannies within the psyche, within the psyche, within the the body, within one's thoughts, feelings. Here in the U.S., where I'm based, I would say the
majority of the shame I treat comes from kind of oppressive or rigid religious institutions that, you know, people grow up hearing the message that sex is wrong, sex is bad, save it for someone you love, which is just very confusing. Why would you want to save something bad for someone you love. And so that alone creates a lot of kind of incongruence in feelings. There's also not, we don't have great sex education in our school system. So, you know, information is power. The more you know, the more comfortable you are. Sex is one of those things that, you know, a lot of parents and schools just don't give kids an instruction manual for. You know, you would never put a kid behind the wheel of a car before talking to them about some, you know, basic rules of the road. But for some reason, a lot of people have this idea that sex is this quote unquote natural thing. And for all intensive purposes, it is. But we still need information about it. You know, I see sexual shame pop up because of, of course, the obvious things like sexual trauma. You know, I see it because of emotional trauma. You know, I see it because of emotional trauma.
family of origin trauma, you know, the messages we internalize about our body, about our ability, our worthiness of being loved, our ability to love, all of that has the potential to contribute to feelings of shame and unworthiness. And then, of course, sexuality as well. And, like, you know, and also sometimes even people write into me feeling that they have sexual shame for not having sex. So it's just like very complicated thing where it's like, okay, you, I feel ashamed for having sex. I feel ashamed when I have sex.
I feel ashamed for not having sex. It's like a past, present, future. Every single person seems to be involved in this because of, as you said, what seems to be quite a social and cultural phenomena. And that's really my next question is what are the social but also the emotional roots of this shame. So how does it kind of take hold? Yeah. So first of all, I'm so glad you brought that up about the shame of not having sex because it's interesting, I think particularly for your listeners, people in their 20s, you know, this demographic holds the most sexually expansive views in modern history.
And so sometimes if people are maybe choosing to be monogamous or not very kinky or, you know, know, you name it, sometimes they can be shamed for that as well. And so, you know, really what it's about is accepting everyone, you know, no matter where they choose to fall and, you know, respecting their right to make that decision for themselves. And so really when we talk about the experience of sexual shame and how that looks, what are some of the ways that that shows up emotionally for us. So what are some of the ways that we might be able to recognize it in ourselves? People who are carrying shame often describe feeling kind of small during sex or in general. They may feel like they have difficulty asserting their wants and needs. They may feel that they
don't have a voice. And it's not just emotional. It can be physical too. I mean, it can, you know, I treat a lot of women who experience pain with intercourse because the shame that they've internalized around sex is so profound that it causes their pelvic floor muscles to tighten up, you know, in a way that's out of their control. And so some of these women are unable to have intercourse because the pelvic floor muscles are kind of clamping shut. It can manifest itself in thoughts as well, feelings of, you know, I'm not worthy enough. I'm not good enough. I don't deserve sexual pleasure. I don't feel that I have sexual autonomy. I don't feel like my sexual desires or needs are important or worthy. You know, it can show up in all different ways,
mental, emotional, and physical. I really like that you brought up the physical side of this as well, because we think about shame is something that's very cognitive, very emotional, as we said, something that impacts us in the mind, not always realizing that, of course, the mind and the body are very, very, very, like, they're the same thing. Yeah, you can't separate them. And trauma, shame, really intense emotions always show up in the body, in muscle tension, in, you know, a suppressed immune system, in sort of. in chronic pain. And as you said, like with shame showing up in like, what was it like pelvic
floor contractions? Yes. Spasms. And spasms, which is like very, very interesting. It's very important, I think, to note that is that your sexual shame is not something that is only going to be, it's not just in your mind. It's something that's very real and very tangible. And when we've experienced it for a long time, how does that, impact our ability to connect with others. And maybe not just like intimately, but emotionally as well. Do you see that have you seen in your practice that the shame sometimes even starts to extend beyond sex? Oh, yeah. I mean, I very rarely distinguish sex from, you know, emotional connection because the two are so inextricably linked in my mind. So people who are carrying shame can enter into a pattern
of unhealthy relationships, maybe because they just don't believe that they are worthy of love that, you know, can be expressed healthy and is multidirectional. They may over-rely on sex to feel affirmed or validated in their relationship, and that can be kind of a pleasure inhibitor. They may kind of tune out during sex and dissociate, which is also a big pleasure inhibitor. And so you know, I think it's really important for people to pay very close attention to the sensations they're experiencing in their body when they are sexual, you know, are you experiencing a tightness in your chest? Shame oftentimes shows up in the gut, you know, we'll get kind of a pit in our stomach or a feeling of nausea. That's that like feeling of disgust. And so it's important
if you're not experiencing pleasure during sex, what sensations are you? experiencing. Just beginning by identifying them and naming them is a really great first step in mindfulness, which can help begin the process of moving them out. I really want to focus on something you just said actually, which was two things, which was overrelying on sex in a relationship and feeling like you're zoning out when you're having sex. Maybe focusing on that first one. Why do people, because obviously when we think sexual shame, we think wanting to avoid sex, right? And wanting and having such negative attitudes towards it that it doesn't have an active role in your life. But what is this over-reliance on in a relationship?
So that stems from a place of an internalized message that you have to have sex or be sexual for someone else rather than for yourself or as part of, you know, a more mutual relational connected experience. So what happens is you kind of take yourself out of the equation and people who do this can have sex that's very performative. You know, they may do things that they don't necessarily like because they think doing so will please their partner and make their partner, you know, more likely to stay with them. And it can kind of fill an emotional void temporarily in the moment because, you know, theoretically, we feel seen when we're naked in bed with another person. But if that feeling of intimacy, that emotional intimacy isn't going both
ways and if it's just to fill someone else's cup because doing so feels good, that feeling is not going to last. It's going to end up, you know, kind of leaving you empty at the end of the day. And I can also imagine I would put such a strain on the relationship because, you know, you're having sex when you don't want to, maybe you want to please them. So it's like a secondary one, right? It's not the primary one of wanting to have sex. It's the secondary one. And I'm sure that actually leads to a lot of resentment as well. Oh, yeah. Yeah. I mean, when you continuously put the needs of other people over your own. Eventually, it does build up your anger and resentment and ultimately drops your self-esteem even more. Again, you've taken yourself out of the equation.
So if someone is dealing with that and they're like, okay, well, actually what I'm finding is I'm just saying yes to how, I'm offering sex even. I'm offering sex, which I'm sure is a big thing because, you know, I know that's what my partner really wants and I actually don't really want it, but I want to make them happy. And I'm feeling so numb when we have sex. I'm actually not even enjoying this. Like, I'm not not enjoying it, but I'm not feeling anything. How would you recommend people address that? Is it to take sex off the table? Or how would you go about that? To an extent, I think it's really helpful. You know, there's always the question, do you address the emotional stuff first or do you address the sexual stuff first? And, you know, most people say,
well, you have to dress the emotional stuff first or else you're not going to be able to heal the sexual stuff. And I take a little bit of a different approach. Like I said earlier, I don't really separate sex and emotion. And so, you know, for people who might be struggling with this, I'll have them take really small baby steps and work their way up. So they're kind of rounding the bases again. That may look like, you know, spending some time cuddling with your partner, maybe even with your clothes on, seeing how it feels to accept like a massage or a caress from your partner without the expectation of doing anything back to them and noticing, you know, what's happening in that moment? Am I fighting the urge to surrender and relax and just enjoy
this moment for myself? Or am I kind of tensing up? Are my thoughts wandering? Is my mind kind of zoning out, just noticing what's happening in that moment and continuing to kind of repeat that several times until you start to, at a minimum, experience it more neutrally and hopefully until you start to have more positive feelings about the experience and then starting to work your way into, you know, more and more sex acts, if you will, that kind of progress things along, just depending on what your comfort level is. Now, you have to have a partner who's willing to help you through this process. You know, there's a lot of healing that can happen within oneself individually, but so much of our healing happens in relation to other people. And it's not uncommon at all for
people who are holding on to shame, like I said, to kind of get into unhealthy relationship patterns. and, you know, I wouldn't recommend doing what I just described with someone who, you know, is toxic or unhealthy for whatever reason. So it may mean that you start this process with a new relationship partner once you have had a bit more time to establish kind of some emotional safety and trust and take your time. I really like that what you just said there, that a lot of healing does happen in relation to others. And perhaps it's a good sign that if you're with someone who is like, No, I'm not going to respect this complete reversal of our intimate lives and this in this complete return to first base, second base. Like, how is that going to be in 20 years? Yeah.
None of this will ever be healed, I think, if something doesn't change. And it might change within the relationship or the relationship might be the thing that needs to change. You know what I mean? Precisely. Precisely. If someone's not willing to take that walk with you hand in hand, then. You know, that's a big red flag. I want to move on to how we can unlearn sexual shame by ourselves.
So without a partner, a single people, maybe as someone who's never even had sex, or as, you know, whatever it is your situation is, if you've found in the past that you're entering intimate situations and just being like, okay, like, my priorities you're out the window, I'm going to do whatever. whatever they want to do or I just feel disgusting after this or whatever it is. How do we unlearn that as a single person or as a solo person? Yeah, such a great question. I'm going to give y'all some really good tools. I say y'all because I'm in Texas. I love it. I was like, it's fun. So first thing you have to know is that the sexual shame you have is not yours to carry. It was put on you by either another individual, by a culture, by a religious institution, by implicit or explicit
negative messages about sex and you, because you're human, have internalized it as your own. But the first step is recognizing that it does not belong to you. That's number one. Number two, you want to identify what the negative thoughts are that you have about. your body, about desire, about asserting your needs, about voicing your preferences, and begin the process of replacing them with the thoughts that you would like to have. So if you hold on to the belief like, my body is not worthy of pleasure, first ask yourself where that belief came from and then flip it into my body was hardwired for pleasure.
and then start doing things that allow you the experience of pleasure. Maybe it starts with non-sexual things. Maybe, you know, enjoying a, you know, really great piece of chocolate or hot tea or, you know, savoring little pleasures in life just to kind of start those pathways and getting them to fire and then gradually working your way, you know, into the intimate realm. I also really love somatic work for this. You know, as we talked about before, shame is stored in the body. So I will literally have people, like, let's say they are experiencing shame because of negative messages they got from the church or maybe even because of a trauma that they experienced.
I will have them write a letter to whoever that person or entity was that made them feel that way. It's not a letter that they will ever give to that person. But I will have them imagine that person sitting in an empty chair across the way. from them and reading the letter aloud. And then I'll have them hold something like a tissue box over the area of their body where they're holding shame and like pull the tissues out one by one. It can kind of like give people the feeling of pulling the emotion off or even getting like a towel and like wiping away the area and the body where that shame is.
those kinds of exercises can actually be really profound and transformative for people. And so just as, you know, the healing begins, you know, I think within an individual, those are a few things that I really like and recommend to clients. Semantic therapy and semantic healing, probably one of my favorite, my favorite forms of healing. Yeah, it's really up there because it's like, again, if trauma and emotions are stored in the body, how could we think that, you know, moving beyond them or processing them or regulating them is not going to include the body. Yeah, exactly.
You can't short-circuiter. No, exactly. We're going to take a quick break, and then we're going to return with Dr. Emily Jamir to talk about sexual confidence and how we can feel good about ourselves. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness,
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross
double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush I gotta do a little kill. Well, you can find out on The Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth.
Are you a good person? because you're afraid. Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing,
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that follow
revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. We are back with Dr. Emily Jamia. and I want to talk about sexual confidence because sexual shame is one thing. But then we might also not have any sexual shame, but just not feel like we really know what we're doing and we're not feeling amazing in our bodies. And I think a big part of sex is just feeling good about yourself. You know, I don't want to have sex with my partner or go on dates or even look for a sexual partner if I don't feel good. And if I don't have sexual confidence. So how is this something that we can build without necessarily just having more.
sex. Yeah. I love this. You know, when people come in with a sexual issue, I'll kind of ask them where they feel like they fall on a scale of negative 10 to positive 10, where negative 10 is like, holy hell and everyone do that again. And positive 10 is like swilling in from the chandeliers. So we've talked so far about how to move out the shame and hopefully gotten people to a place of neutrality. But this is like the fun part. Like how do we start building the positive feelings and sensations that we want to experience so that we can, you know, explore and experience our full sexual and erotic potential. Once you have hopefully relearned some thoughts or change some beliefs that you may hold, I think it's really helpful to talk to other people who maybe are in
your circle who are more sexually confident. You know, we feed off each other's energy. And people who are holding shame, like I said before, oftentimes don't feel. like they have much of a voice. And so, you know, hopefully at this point in the game, people are starting to feel more comfortable with the idea, at least, of great sex. Talking to a friend, you know, find the Samantha in your group. I don't know if your listeners watch sex in the city or if, like, they're too young for that. But they definitely, they definitely do. Okay. Good. So, you know, find the friend who, you know, has kind of an unabashed, you know, feeling about her sexuality or his sexuality and ask them what that's like for them. And you will see
them start to light up. You will see their posture open up. You will see them sit a little taller. And ideally, that will kind of invite your body to do the same. We have mirror neurons in our brain. So when one person, you know, for example, describes what it's like to eat a warm chocolate chip cookie, our brains, if looked at under an MRI, can light up as if we're the ones, experiencing eating the cookie. So talking to people who feel really great about their sexuality can be a really simple, easy way to just begin getting a sense of what it's like to have some of those feelings within your own body. I also think we need to spend more time naked. You know, you cannot expect to feel totally comfortable and open with your body in the presence of
她们开始亮起来。你会看到她们的姿态变得开放。你会看到她们坐得稍微挺拔了一些。理想情况下，这也将引导你的身体做出同样的反应。我们的大脑中存在镜像神经元。因此，当一个人，比如说，在描述吃一块温热的巧克力曲瓜饼是什么感觉时，如果我们通过核磁共振去观察，我们的大脑就会被激活，就像是我们自己正在体验吃曲奇饼一样。因此，与那些对自己性观念感觉很好的人交谈，可以成为一种非常简单、轻松的方式，让你开始体会到在自己的身体里拥有这种感觉是什么滋味。我也认为我们需要花更多的时间赤身裸体。要知道，如果在
another person if you can't do so yourself. So I would. will have people, you know, slowly undress in front of the mirror and, you know, look at and explore their body, touch themselves head to toe, move around. You know, a lot of women have never looked at their genitalia or their vulvas in a mirror before. So, you know, getting comfortable with how your vulva looks or how, you know, your penis looks. Guys are used to it because it's external, but a lot of women haven't. You know, educating yourself as much as possible, like I said before, knowledge is power, you know, understand and know your own anatomy. Self pleasure is huge. So, you know, begin to discover what feels good to you. Sometimes you don't know what you don't know.
另一个人的面前，你甚至无法在自己面前做到这一点，你就不能指望对自己的身体感到完全的舒适和开放。所以我会让人们，你知道，在镜子里慢慢脱光衣服，然后，你知道，看着并探索自己的身体，从头到脚抚摸自己，四处走动。要知道，很多女性以前从来没有在镜子里看过自己的生殖器或外阴。所以，你知道，习惯你的外阴看起来是什么样，或者，你知道，你的阴茎看起来是什么样。男生们已经习惯了，因为它是外露的，但很多女性没有。你知道，尽可能多地教育自己，就像我之前说的，知识就是力量，你知道，理解并了解你自己的解剖结构。自我愉悦至关重要。所以，你知道，开始去发现什么能给你带来美好的感觉。有时你不知道自己不知道什么。
So finding, you know, there's tons of lists online. I have one in my book, like a yes, no, maybe type of list where, you know, you see all different kinds of things you might do sexually mapped out and you can start to think about what you would be comfortable with versus maybe not so much, just to start having an idea so that when you are with a partner, you can start expressing those desires, you know, rather than just kind of submitting to them and letting them do what they think feels good to you. So, you know, those are just a few things I think people can do that really go a long way and boosting confidence. Do you want to hear a funny story? I would love to.
所以去寻找，你知道，网上有大量的清单。我的书里也有一份，类似于“是、否、也许”那种类型的清单，你可以在上面看到各种你可能会在性生活中尝试的不同事情，并开始思考哪些是你能够接受的，哪些可能不太能接受，这只是为了让你有个概念，这样当你和伴侣在一起时，你就可以开始表达这些欲望，你知道，而不是只是顺从他们，让他们去做他们认为你会觉得舒服的事。所以，你知道，这些只是我认为人们可以做的几件事情，它们对建立自信大有帮助。你想听一个有趣的故事吗？我非常想听。
About what, so when you said we need to spend more time naked, I'm going to tell a funny story about an interaction with a listener. Because I'm a big, I'm just revealing myself yet. I'm a big fan of this. Maybe because I like grew up, like, I don't know, when we were kids, we'd always run around naked. Like, we were fine with our bodies and all those things. And I remember probably a couple of months ago, I was at a beach in Sydney. That's a nude beach. Because why not?
关于什么的呢？当你刚才说我们需要花更多时间赤身裸体时，我要讲一个关于我和听众互动的有趣故事。因为我是一个——我还在自我暴露呢——我是这方面的超级大粉丝。也许是因为我从小到大，我不知道，当我们还是小孩子的时候，我们总是光着身子到处跑。我们对自己的身体以及所有这些事情都感觉很自然。我记得大概几个月前，我在悉尼的一个海滩上。那是一个天体海滩。因为为什么不呢？
It's like a women's nude beach. It's very popular. And I'm in the water with my friends and we're splashing around fully naked, having the best time, just being very, very open and the sun is shining. And I come up back up onto like the little dock area. And these girls have kind of been watching me. And I'm like, I was like, oh, like, am I embarrassing myself? You know, we're being pretty open about it and they go, oh my gosh, are you the host of the psychology of your 20s? And I hope they're listening to this episode because I just turned beat red. Oh my God. I was so embarrassed. So if you like even do it, and you know what, but I survived. So even doing
那是一个女子天体海滩。非常受欢迎。我和朋友们在水里，我们一丝不挂地嬉戏，度过了最美好的时光，表现得非常非常开放，阳光灿烂。然后我回到了那个类似于小码头的地方。有些女孩一直在看着我。我当时想，哦，天哪，我是不是在出丑？你知道的，我们对此表现得相当开放，她们走过来问：哦，天哪，你是《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of your 20s）的主持人吗？我希望她们正在听这一集，因为当时我的脸一下子涨得通红。哦，天哪。我当时尴尬极了。所以，如果你甚至去这样做，你知道吗，但我挺过来了。所以，甚至去做
things like that, like it's a funny story now. I was I was mortified and I'm not someone who's embarrassed either. But even doing something like that, I was like, wow, that made me feel really weird, but then actually afterwards now it's become a funny story, and it's about turning what could have been a really embarrassing, shameful experience into one that is something you can laugh about and that you can be like, well, of course, that's where people would see me because that's what I do. Like, that's how I enjoy my life and I enjoy my city and I enjoy the water and all those things. So I love that. And it probably not only inspired those listeners, but gave you a lot more street cred that you, like, actually practice what you preach on the show.
那样的事情，现在想来也是个有趣的故事。我当时简直尴尬死了，而且我也不是那种容易觉得尴尬的人。但哪怕是做了那样的事，我也在想，哇，那让我感觉真的很诡异，但事后回想起来，这变成了一个有趣的故事，而且它关乎于如何将一段可能非常尴尬、充满羞耻的经历，转变成一件你可以一笑了之的事情，你可以觉得：好吧，当然啦，人们会在那里看到我，因为这就是我所做的事。这就是我享受生活、享受我的城市、享受水流以及所有这些事情的方式。所以我很喜欢这样。这不仅可能激励了那些听众，还为你树立了更多真实的信誉，证明你确实在践行自己在节目中所宣扬的理念。
I sure do. I was playing mermaids naked in the beach. So there you go, everybody. There's a little tip of it. I'm going to move back on to my actual professional real life questions about a very important topic. But what advice would you maybe give someone who wants to fully embrace and explore their sexuality without a partner and not solo? look, how could you go about asking for what you want in sex whenever you want to, I guess, have sex? Yeah. So a lot of people ask me that question and they'll add to that question and without it feeling awkward. And I'm like, step one is you lean into the feeling of awkward. And you may even lead with that. You know, you can say something along the lines of, listen, I have been doing a lot of personal work on myself lately, trying to feel more confident. And I am still, I've made a lot of
我当然是。我当时在海滩上像个裸体美人鱼一样玩耍。所以大家看吧，这就是一点小花絮。我要回到我实际的职业现实生活中关于一个非常重要的话题的提问了。但是，对于那些想要在没有伴侣陪伴的情况下，完全拥抱并探索自己的性欲、而不是独自进行的人，你会有什么建议呢？你看，每当你想做爱的时候，你该如何开口去表达你在性爱中想要的东西呢？是的。所以很多人都会问我这个问题，他们还会补充问：而且要如何做到不让人感到尴尬呢？而我的回答是：第一步，你要去迎合这种尴尬的感觉。你甚至可以直接以此为开场白。你知道，你可以说一些类似这样的话：听着，我最近一直在对自己做很多内省的工作，努力让自己感到更自信。而且我虽然已经取得了很大
progress, but I'm still working on my confidence with other people. And even saying this to you is kind of awkward and uncomfortable for me. But I heard on Psychology of your 20s that putting that out there, you know, can go a long way and helping me feel closer to you. Because it does, you know, inviting your partner to be a part of the process is intimacy building. You know, that is relational. Like I said before, shame is put on you, but pleasure oftentimes happens, you know, in relation to another person. And you can say, you know, I'm still exploring sexuality. I don't even know what I don't know.
进展，但我还在努力建立自己在他人面前的自信。甚至对你说出这些话，对我来说也是一种尴尬和不舒服。但我在《你二十岁的心理学》里听说，把这些说出来，你知道，对于帮我拉近与你之间的距离大有帮助。因为确实如此，你知道，邀请你的伴侣参与到这个过程中来本身就是一种建立亲密关系的行为。你知道，那是建立在人际关系基础上的。就像我之前说的，羞耻感是别人强加给你的，但快乐往往是在与另一个人的关系中发生的。你可以说，你知道，我还在探索我的性观念。我甚至对很多事一无所知。
But, you know, I think we have a really great connection. We have established some trust. And, you know, I just want to ask you to be supportive through this journey. And I'm going to practice with you asserting my desires and. expressing my needs and I want to know if you're okay with that. A good partner is going to say like, heck yes, I want to be a part of this journey with you. You know, anyone who replies with anything less enthusiastic than that probably isn't the right partner for you to begin this process with. So yeah, to summarize, just kind of lead with it, hey, this is uncomfortable for me, but I trust you.
但是，你知道，我认为我们之间的联系非常棒。我们已经建立了一定的信任。而且，你知道，我只想请求你在这个旅程中给予我支持。我将和你一起练习坚定我的欲望、表达我的需求，我想知道你是否能接受这一点。一个好的伴侣会说：太棒了，我非常想和你一起经历这段旅程。你知道，任何回答得比这还要不热情的人，可能都不是开启这个过程的正确伴侣。所以，是的，总而言之，只要顺着这种感觉说出来，嘿，这让我感到不舒服，但我信任你。
Can you hold my hand through this process? And I guess also if it's like a person, and that you're not dating, like a, you know, a little bit of a fling or like a little bit of a hookup. I feel like the worst thing they can say is no. Maybe they could tell other people, but honestly, anytime someone has told me any details about someone else in their sex life, I've been like, you're the asshole. Like, I've never thought any poor, I've never thought poor thoughts about someone who someone else's, you know, uninvited, unolicited, told me something about them intimately. Yeah. Yeah. So I think if that's what you're worried about, you've got to realize that no one who is actually a decent person will judge you for your sexual desires as long as they're obviously legal and not hurting other people. You know, if that's what you're embarrassed about. Embarrassment sometimes comes with the territory, right? It does. Now, look, we don't see the embarrassing stuff that happens all the time during sex in movies and TV. They edit that part out, right? But.
你能在这个过程中拉着我的手吗？我想，如果对方是一个你并没有在约会的人，比如，你知道，只是短暂的一夜情或者某种随意的约会对象。我觉得他们能说的最糟糕的话也就是“不”。也许他们会告诉其他人，但老实说，每当有人向我透露关于别人性生活细节的任何事情时，我心里都会想：你真是个混蛋。我从来没有对那些隐私被别人不请自来、未经允许地向我透露的人产生过任何不好的想法，从来没有。是的。所以，如果你担心的是这一点，你必须意识到，任何真正有品德的人都不会因为你的性欲望而对你评头论足，只要这些欲望显然是合法的，并且没有伤害到其他人。你知道，如果你担心的是这种尴尬的话。尴尬有时就是这个过程的一部分，对吧？确实如此。现在，你看，我们在电影和电视里看不到在性爱过程中一直发生的所有那些尴尬的事情。他们把那部分剪掉了，对吧？但是。
I mean, there's going to be a weird noise or an awkward position or a wet spot. Like, you know, that's just sex is wonderful and pleasurable and joyish, but it can be messy too. And that's okay. You know, I want to say, though, I would caution anyone on this, on kind of initiating this process with a casual sex partner because I do think that trust and safety are such an important foundation in healing shame. So, you know, ideally you want to do it with someone who you've established that with. Yeah, very good advice. I want to just move on to one final section of questioning, which is about libido. People ask me about libido all the time.
我是说，总会有奇怪的声音、尴尬的姿势或者湿漉漉的痕迹。你知道，性是美妙的、快乐的、令人愉悦的，但它也可能会很凌乱。这没关系。不过我想说的是，对于同随意性伴侣开启这个过程，我还是要提醒大家保持谨慎，因为我认为信任和安全感是治愈羞耻感的重要基础。所以，你知道，理想情况下，你还是希望和已经建立起这种基础的人一起去做这件事。是的，非常好的建议。我想接着探讨最后一个问题，那就是关于性欲。人们总是向我询问关于性欲的事情。
And obviously, I've had my own personal experiences, but it was something I always didn't really want to touch because I was like I was waiting for the right guest. And here you are. So now I have all these listener questions that I wanted to answer for so long, because people do really struggle with it. And you think that you shouldn't struggle with libido in your 20s because you should be, you know, ready to have sex and like super into it all the time. Constantly, you're young, the fittest and healthy as you've maybe ever been. A lot of these experiences might be new and you're the early days in relationships, whatever it is. People feel a lot of pressure.
很显然，我自己也有过相关的个人经历，但这曾是我一直不太想触碰的话题，因为我当时在等待合适的嘉宾。而你现在来了。所以现在我有了所有这些积攒了很久、我一直想解答的听众提问，因为人们确实在这方面挣扎。你可能会觉得，在二十多岁的时候，你不应该在性欲上有任何挣扎，因为你应该，你知道，时刻准备好做爱，并且总是对它超级感兴趣。源源不断地，你还年轻，身体状况也许是你一生中最健美、最健康的时期。许多这样的经历对你来说可能是崭新的，你正处于恋爱的早期阶段，无论具体情况如何。人们感受到了巨大的压力。
We're having sex all the time. what would you say to someone who feels like their libido is almost too high or too low? Yeah, so we have to first, we can't pathologize people who have low libido necessarily. I mean, ideally you want to partner up with someone who approximates your level of interest. Couples run into trouble when there's a really big gap between how much or little someone wants to experience sex. You know, there are also people who identify as being asexual who just, you know, aren't in touch with that part of their life. And there's no problem with that. You know, they have really meaningful friendships. They might even have romantic relationships that don't include sex. You know, but there's a lot happening in our 20s. I think the biggest shift is that people are beginning to make the transition from kind of hormone-driven sex to emotional. driven sex, you know, the prefrontal cortex part of our brain isn't fully formed until we're 25. And, you know, a lot of the sexual desire and urges that happen prior to that, in part, are coming
我们一直在做爱。你会对那些觉得自己性欲几乎太高或太低的人说些什么呢？是的，所以我们首先必须认识到，我们不能强行把那些性欲低下的人病理化。我的意思是，理想情况下，你希望和一个与你的兴趣水平相近的人结成伴侣。当一个人对性体验的需求程度存在巨大差距时，伴侣之间就会遇到问题。你知道，还有一些人认为自己是无性恋者，他们只是，你知道，没有和生活中的那一部分建立联系。这并没有什么问题。你知道，他们拥有非常有意义的友谊。他们甚至可能拥有不包含性行为的浪漫关系。你知道，但在我们的二十多岁，有很多事情在发生。我认为最大的转变是，人们开始从那种由荷尔蒙驱动的性，向情感驱动的性过渡，你知道，我们大脑中的前额叶皮层直到25岁才完全发育成熟。并且，你知道，在此之前发生的许多性欲望和冲动，在某种程度上来自于
from this kind of surge of hormones, you know, that are pushing us to potentially reproduce and, you know, pair bond and things like that. But as those hormones and neurochemicals start to level out, we're starting to, I think, in our 20s and especially later 20s, I would say, kind of discover and explore what motivates us to have sex from an emotional place, from an interpersonal place. And so, you know, I'm not surprised to hear that, you know, your listeners may kind of struggle to understand their libido in their 20s. You know, I'm a sex therapist. I've been doing this work since my early 20s. And, you know, hindsight's always 2020. I feel like I didn't. really fully come into my own until I was over the age of 30, you know. So it just, I think, takes time for people as we mature and have kind of more maturely, you know, driven sex. It's, it's different from how it is when we're, you know, in our adolescence and early 20s. I really, I like that you just said that it got better, like after 30. Like, that's when you really came into your own. Yeah. I mean, I've done a lot of research on Desire. It's what I wrote a book about.
这种汹涌而来的荷尔蒙，你知道，它们在推动我们去进行潜在的繁育、建立伴侣关系以及诸如此类的事情。但随着这些荷尔蒙和神经化学物质开始趋于平稳，我认为在我们的二十多岁，尤其是二十多岁后期，我可以说，我们开始发现并探索是什么在情感层面、在人际关系层面激励着我们去过性生活。所以，你知道，听到你的听众可能在二十多岁时难以理解他们的性欲，我并不感到惊讶。你知道，我是一名性治疗师。我从二十出头就开始从事这项工作了，你知道，事后诸葛亮总是最准的。我觉得直到我三十岁以后，我才真正完全找到了自我，你知道的。所以这只是，我认为随着我们成熟，以及拥有那种更成熟驱动的性体验，这需要时间。它与我们在青春期和二十岁出头时的状态是不同的。我真的很喜欢你刚才说的那种感觉——情况变得更好了，尤其是在30岁之后。就像那是你真正找到自我的时期。是的。我是说，我对欲望做过很多研究。这是我写书的主题。
And, you know, I talked to a lot of people who maintained a strong sexual connection through the decades to find out what they did to sustain it. And none of them talked about sex in their 20s being the best sex of their lives. And none of them talked about the honeymoon stage being the greatest sex they had experienced. So we have to like totally move past the idea that great sex is reserved for like the young and able-bodied because that or only exist within the early stages of a relationship because that couldn't be further from the truth. And I really enjoyed that you said libido as an idea. Like it's it's really about finding someone who matches that. And therefore I think perhaps the shame disappears when it's like,
而且，你知道，我采访过许多在几十年里一直保持强烈性联系的人，以了解他们是如何维持这种关系的。他们中没有人认为自己二十多岁的性生活是他们一生中最棒的性生活，也没有人认为蜜月期是他们体验过的最美好的性。所以我们必须彻底抛弃那种“美妙的性爱只属于年轻且身体健全的人”的想法，或者它只存在于关系的早期阶段，因为这与事实相去甚远。而且我真的很喜欢你把性欲看作是一种理念的说法。这就好比是去寻找一个与你合拍的人。因此，我想当出现这种情况时，羞耻感或许就消失了，因为你会觉得：
oh my God, I don't feel like I have to keep saying no. Or I don't feel like I have to keep saying yes, you know what I mean? So it's really, really very fun. I have one final question for you, and I really want you to talk about your book a little bit, because if you've enjoyed this episode, I'd be like your book is just like the perfect companion. But this is the question I ask every single guest on the show, which is what is your biggest piece of advice for people in their 20s, and it doesn't have to be what we spoke about today.
哦天哪，我不再觉得我必须一直说“不”了。或者我不再觉得我必须一直说“好”了，你知道我的意思吗？所以这真的是非常非常有趣。我有一个最后的问题想问你，我真的很希望你能多谈谈你的书，因为如果你喜欢这一集，我会觉得你的书就是绝配。但这是我问节目中每一位嘉宾的相同问题，那就是：对于处于二十多岁的人群，你最大的建议是什么？而且这不一定非得和我们今天谈论的内容相关。
The best is yet to come. You know, I think that's what I would say. You know, the 20s is, your 20s is a time of transformation and, you know, self-exploration and understanding. But I, you know, when I was in my early 20s, I had a therapist who said, you know, Emily, I think you need to really think hard about making any long-term relationship decisions until you're at least 30 because you just don't know. know yourself until then. And she was right. You know, I just think that what I want to encourage people to do in their 20s is continue to explore and push themselves outside their comfort zone and have new experiences and meet people and know that through that you will grow in your own understanding. But I think as we mature, God, I'm sounding really old right now. But I think as we
最美好的还在后头。你知道，我想这就是我想说的。你知道，二十多岁是，你的二十多岁是一个充满转变、自我探索和理解的时期。但是，你知道，当我二十出头的时候，我有一位治疗师曾对我说，你知道，艾米丽，我认为你在至少30岁之前，需要认真考虑任何长期的恋爱决定，因为直到那个时候你才真正了解自己。而她是正确的。你知道，我只是觉得我想鼓励人们在二十多岁时做的事情，就是继续探索并把自己推向舒适区之外，去拥有新的体验，去结识新的人，并且要知道，通过这些，你会对自我有更深的理解。但是我想随着我们成熟——天哪，我听起来现在真的很老了。但我认为随着我们
mature. The confidence that comes with that brings about such a sense of peace that in many ways life feels a lot easier. You know what? That made me feel great. The best is here to come. As someone who's made their career on their 20s so far, I think that's definitely something that I needed to hear. So where can people find your book? And more generally, what is it about? What could they, what kind of information and learnings will they hopefully take from it? Yeah. So, you know, what inspired my book is I'd been doing this work for like 15 years and I could help people improve desire, orgasms, you know, help women overcome pain, that sort of thing. But people often came back like wanting more intensity, more impassion, more passion. And as I started paying closer
成熟。随之而来的自信会带来一种深深的平静感，在许多方面，生活会感觉容易得多。你知道吗？这让我感觉好极了。最美好的还在后头。作为一个至今为止都将事业建立在“二十多岁”这一主题上的人，我认为这绝对是我需要听到的建议。那么人们能在哪里找到你的书呢？更广义地说，这本书是关于什么的？他们能从中获得什么样的信息和学习成果呢？是的。所以，你知道，启发我写这本书的原因是，我已经从事这方面的工作大约15年了，我能帮助人们提升欲望、体验高潮，你知道，帮助女性克服疼痛，诸如此类的事情。但人们经常回来寻求更多，想要更多的强度、更多的热情、更多的激情。当我开始密切关注
attention to the language they were using. I realized, you know, words like effortless. I want to feel lost in the moment. I want the world around me to disappear. I'm like, they're talking about a flow state. For people listening who don't know what a flow state is, it's when we are engaged in an activity in which we experience that complete absorption, a sense of merger, loss of space and time, like a surfer who's at one with the wave. And I was like, well, yeah, like, of course people want to experience a flow state during sex. That's like what gives it that transcendent feel. So I turned to the literature to see what I could find and there was nothing out there. I couldn't find a single paper that looked at the research or I'm sorry, at the relationship between great sex and flow state.
他们所使用的语言时。我意识到，你知道，像“不费力气”这样的词。我想在当下迷失自我。我希望我周围的世界消失。我想：他们在谈论心流状态（flow state）。对于那些不知道什么是心流状态的听众，它是指我们全神贯注于某项活动中，体验到完全的沉浸感、融合感、失去时空感，就像一个与海浪融为一体的冲浪者。而我在想：是的，当然人们希望在性爱中体验到心流状态。这正是赋予它那种超越感的原因。所以我查阅了相关文献，看看能找到什么，结果却一无所获。我找不到一篇研究优秀性爱与心流状态之间关系的研究论文。
So I did my own research study, went on to publish my findings and that eventually set the premise for the book. I called up, you know, my research participants and had really, long conversations with them, with the ones that got high scores about what precisely they did to experience the state of flow during sex. And these five themes emerged, which are the five secrets in the book. So we've got sensuality, curiosity, adaptability, vulnerability, and attunement. And woven through those secrets is the science of flow. And I think what's really exciting to me about those five qualities is that we're born. with them. You know, look at any child. They are born sensual, curious, with the ability to attune,
所以我做了自己的研究，并最终发表了我的发现，这最终为这本书奠定了前提。我给我的研究参与者打了电话，与那些获得高分的人进行了非常长时间的对话，探讨他们在性爱中究竟做了什么来体验这种心流状态。然后这五个主题浮现出来，这也是书中的五个秘密。它们分别是：感官性（sensuality）、好奇心（curiosity）、适应性（adaptability）、脆弱性（vulnerability）和共鸣（attunement）。贯穿这些秘密的是心流科学。而且我认为这五种品质最让我兴奋的是，我们生来就具备它们。
to adapt to new environments. And so this is really, it explores, you know, not becoming someone that you're not, but really about looking within and reconnecting with qualities that are already there within us. I am sold. I'm sold. I feel I love those five things. Like that just describe as passion in any area of your life, right? Like, that's so brilliant. This might be like an out-of-left-field question, but what was your favorite secret? What was your favorite chapter or section of the book to write? I think curiosity was probably my favorite. I think it is the one that makes the most sense to people. You know, I think most people have an idea that sexual novelty is good for long-term satisfaction, and that's reflected in the research. But
看看任何一个小孩子。他们生来就充满感官意识、好奇心，具备与人共鸣、
I explore it in a way that I think is a bit different from how most people think of it. Flow state has eight components. And one of the most predictable ways to experience flow in anything is something called the challenge skills ratio. So what we know from flow state science is that we want the challenge of what we're doing to be just 4% greater than our skill set. If the challenge is too high, we experience anxiety and fear. If the challenge is too low, we experience boredom and monotony.
适应新环境的能力。所以这实际上是在探索，你知道，不是去变成一个你本来不是的人，而是去向内看，重新连接那些本来就存在于我们体内的品质。我被说服了。我被说服了。我觉得我太喜欢这五点啦。这些词简直就能用来形容你生活中任何领域的激情，对吧？真的太棒了。这可能是一个有些突兀的问题，但你最喜欢哪个秘密？写书时你最喜欢的章节或部分是哪个？好奇心可能是我最喜欢的。我认为它是最能让人感同身受的一个。你知道，我认为大多数人都知道性新鲜感对长期满意度是有益的，这一点也在研究中得到了反映。但是
That's kind of where a lot of people end up with sex. But when people start exploring, sometimes they just dive into the deep end way too fast because the difference was too great. So, you know, I think what I talk about in the book is, you know, how to strike that balance between familiarity and, you know, and novelty so that, you know, it just doesn't take much to get in the zone and how to have those conversations with your partner. And I just really enjoyed writing that chapter because I also encourage a lot of self-exploration. Like, you know, this whole episode we've been talking about how to release shame and inhibition. And I have a whole section in that chapter about how to think about your sexual values and explore how maybe they've changed today versus what you've
我以一种我认为与大多数人的理解略有不同的方式去探讨它。心流状态有八个组成部分。在任何事情中体验心流最可预测的方法之一，就是所谓的“挑战与技能比率”（challenge skills ratio）。所以我们从心流状态科学中了解到，我们希望我们所做事情的挑战性比我们的技能水平高出4%左右。如果挑战太高，我们就会体验到焦虑和恐惧。如果挑战太低，我们就会体验到无聊和单调。
kind of taken on as the default. And I have a questionnaire in there. So it, it touches on a lot of different areas of growth within sexuality, which I think a lot of people can relate to. I think that's a beautiful summary. And I'm really hoping that a lot of you guys find what you're looking for in this book, and the same way that you hopefully found what you were looking for. In this episode, I'm going to leave a link to where you can, is it pre-order? It's available. Yeah. I was going to. I'm saying. Yeah.
这正是许多人在性生活方面最终陷入的境地。但当人们开始探索时，有时他们会一头扎进深水区，速度太快，因为两者的差距太大了。所以，你知道，我认为我在书中讨论的是，如何在那种熟悉感和新鲜感之间取得平衡，这样，你知道，不需要付出太多努力就能进入状态，以及如何与你的伴侣进行这些对话。我真的很享受写那一章的过程，因为我也鼓励大量的自我探索。就像，你知道，这一整集我们都在讨论如何释放羞耻感和压抑。我在那一章里有一个完整的章节，关于如何思考你的性价值观，并探索它们今天可能发生了怎样的变化，与你最初作为默认选项全盘接受的东西有何不同。我在那里放了一份问卷。所以它触及了性观念发展中的许多不同领域，我认为很多人都能对此产生共鸣。我认为这是一个极好的总结。我真的希望你们中的许多人能在这本书中找到你们寻找的东西，就像你们希望在这集节目中找到你们寻找的东西一样。我要在节目简介里留一个链接，在哪里可以，是预购吗？已经上市了。是的。我本来要说。我是说。
Most people come on for pre-orders and I'm like, oh, wait, maybe not this time. I will leave a link in the episode description where you can order this book, The Anatomy of Desire. And I have tons of like online learning materials that are free with purchase. So be sure to like go back over to my website after you get the book and you fill out a form and you'll get like hundreds of dollars worth of like free stuff. So it's a good deal. Guys, that's an investment. That really is an investment. Well, thank you again for coming on the podcast. I hope that everyone who listened, enjoyed this episode and got something out of it.
大多数人来上节目都是为了宣传预购，而我在想：哦，等等，这次也许不用了。我会在剧集简介里留下一个链接，你可以在那里订购这本书——《欲望的解剖》（The Anatomy of Desire）。并且我还有大量随书附赠的免费在线学习材料。所以一定要在买完书后回到我的网站上，填一份表，然后你就能获得价值数百美元的免费资料。所以这绝对是一笔划算的买卖。伙计们，这是一笔投资。这真的是一笔投资。那么再次感谢你来到播客。我希望每一个收听的听众都喜欢这一集，并从中有所收获。
Feel free to send it to someone, maybe a partner who you think could really get something out of this episode as well. Maybe a friend, someone you've spoken to about these themes and these topics before. As always, if you have episode suggestions, if you want to continue the conversation, if you have feedback or further comments about this episode, you can always DM me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. And until next time, stay safe. Be kind, be gentle to yourself. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
欢迎随时把它分享出去，也许可以发给一个你认为也能从中获益的伴侣。或者发给一个朋友，一个你以前和她讨论过这些主题和话题的人。一如既往，如果你有节目建议，如果你想继续这个对话，如果你有关于这一集的反馈或进一步的评论，你随时可以在Instagram上私信我，账号是That Psychology Podcast。直到下一次，保重。善待自己，对温柔以待。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships. And you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇特的现代世界中建立心理韧性的方法。经历一些艰难困苦。你将浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。请在IHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。播客名称是“TWO%”。
On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
在《回顾往昔》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，那对我的意义重大。84年对我来说也很重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。在每一集中，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段日期的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同仁喜剧演员以及我们最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅聊80年代。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important. important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games.
84年真是疯狂的一年。那真是个疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人群体来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听的是由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）带来的《艰难中学》（Learn the Hard Way）。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都绝对不安全、无法坦诚进行的对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一身盔甲？它向世界释放的信号是：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你具备这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去这么做。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《艰难中学》。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
你对这份特定的检测报告造假了两次，艾伦女士，对吧？我造假了一次检测。这动用了成群的互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样遭遇的男子。格雷格，一名女同性恋者，迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子彻底炸裂了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱的陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一档IHeart播客。真人保证。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。